Speaker 1: We don't usually do entertainment
stories on this show, but I do want to talk
about something that happened last night.
Comedian Dave Chappelle was attacked on
stage by an individual believed to be armed
while performing at the L.A. Hollywood Bowl.
There are a number of different videos from
audience members cell phones which started to
flood social media, and they showed a man, a man
appear to run on to stage the stage and tackle
Dave Chappelle. LAPD told CBS L.A. that it
was a 23 year old man armed with a replica
handgun that contained a knife blade arrested
and accused of assault with a deadly weapon.
Police identified him as Isaiah Lee and were
holding him on $30,000 bail. Dave Chappelle
reportedly not injured in the attack.
We're not going to show a picture of
the attacker being brought out. His arm is
completely mangled as a result of how he was
handled by security. And that type of imagery is
not allowed on many of our platforms. There is a
joke that was made by Chris Rock. Now, this is
just sort of a strange, random thing. Chris Rock,
who was slapped by Will Smith at the Oscars
recently, was in attendance, and he came up and
told the following joke after the incident.
Unidentified: Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow. Who's
that? Smith.
Speaker 1:
Okay. So people having a good time with
that. So why am I talking about this?
Listen. We cannot have a culture where
this is okay. All right. Now, initially,
it was sort of like asserted without evidence
that the attacker was a trans man attacking Dave
Chappelle. For Chappelle's recently controversial
comments on transgenderism in a Netflix special,
that that has not been demonstrated right
now. And if it was asserted without evidence
and it puts the spotlight on trans people who may
have nothing to do with this, and even if this was
a trans person to group trans people under what
one person that that's that's absolutely terrible
if that happened. Okay. But we can't have a
culture where it is even remotely acceptable
to do this. Now, I'm not saying we do. People
were mostly booing this individual. They were
supportive of Dave Chappelle. People mostly have
not been supportive of Will Smith slapping Chris
Rock. But this is the type of thing where violence
begets violence and then it creates the need for,
you know, even more security at sporting events.
The same thing has been going on. There was a
recent NBA game. I apologize. I don't have the
details. It might have been the Milwaukee Bucks.
I'm not sure where people were running on to the
court. And I think there might have been some
animal rights connection related to the owner
of the team or I don't have the details,
but it's this sort of thing where people were
showing up and to demonstrate against the owner,
they were running onto the court and trying to
approach players. And then so you see even more
security and then you see even rougher treatment
of people who attempt to enter the field of play.
We are seeing people being assaulted for saying
things that others don't like. Now I want to
make a clear line here. I am sensitive to the idea
that sometimes there are forms of speech that are
violent towards groups of people. Okay. So
you can make the case that banning abortion,
which is a legislative act that a state can do.
This has been it's a big topic, so I'm choosing
this one. You could say banning abortion is a form
of violence against women. I'm sensitive to that.
I am absolutely sensitive to that. But we're not
going to solve it by showing up and attacking the
legislators. We're going to solve it by voting
all of them out, putting in legislators that will
legalize abortion. That's the path forward.
And we could always say, Yeah, but but it's
gerrymandering and it's stacked against us. Well,
then we got to fix that. I have not seen evidence
that just physically attacking the individuals
who say the things we don't like is an acceptable
means of change. And I recognize the difference
between. The action of banning abortion. Versus
Dave Chappelle saying something in a special
people don't like. Those are two different things.
I don't believe violence is going
to be the solution in either. And so
we all have to condemn this stuff. We can condemn
the things Dave Chappelle said, but we also have
to condemn the violence. And it's I don't like the
direction that this is going. And I want to hear
from you in the audience as to your perspective
on what I think is an unfortunately growing trend.